what this is great this is not this
isn't even on YouTube I don't think this
thing oh no oh no no yes there's no
geyser in the comments or pockets Matt
Cox and his girlfriend Rebecca Hawk are
on the run Cox has swindled more than
four million dollars for banks in Tampa
in a mortgage fraud scam and he's hungry
for more hungry is one of the hardest
hit cities by mortgage from probably
through babies about to get worse I fell
for some hope so hard and so fast he
just made you think that it was no big
deal that you know what he was doing was
fine and then he would say if it ever
comes to it just blame me
you know you won't you won't get Jamal
take the blame for everything Thaksin
hawk go looking for a house to rent with
a plan to take over the homeowners
identity I remember this tell me that
people believed women more than they
believed a man
Hawk using the name Grace Hudson poses
as a single woman looking to rent this
house it really Retta
so how did you go about making that the
the older ideally they do is that all
with like that's [ __ ] laminate bro
that's just laminate the PLA exacto
knife and a printer or printing machine
yep my laptop I did you have Photoshop
back then they had foot we that we've
had this conversations they had
insurance they've had Photoshop but I
just used word and I just lined up
everything was identical I lined up all
the fonts all the spacings everything
exactly the way it would be when you
printed on license or on word then I
just printed out on a piece of laminate
in Reverse okay so that then when you
have the actual driver the actual piece
of plastic I would just take 220 grit
sandpaper and lightly sand off the
actual in from that text like your real
name so I have the Holograms I have the
Florida ID where it's
Florida Florida Florida that whole thing
I have your picture I have everything
the state of the the state of the
Sunshine State and all that everything
in green is lodged into the - right
that's what you left on there you didn't
sand that off no and I think in black
you see in just that just yet just the
information right like I would leave the
other stuff like your issue day
expiration height all that [ __ ]
signature no signature I would have that
she'd have to sign like disgrace huh see
okay so I would then print the laminate
overlay it glue it on with an actual
glue stick now you got the piece of
plastic with the thing flip it over
take an exacto knife and exacto knife it
around take some to doing it 220 grit
sandpaper buff off the sides hit it a
couple of times beat it up a little bit
like any license you've got in your
pocket for six months it's beat up a
little bit and then I'll you can go in
and say boom boom a million bucks here's
here's my name and they look at it and
they make a copy and they you know even
if they ran the net the number would
work like you could go through check
systems open bank account dozens and
dozens are does I've got a [ __ ] load of
[ __ ] banks opened using a fake
driver's license guys names wrong it's a
completely fabricated any of these did
you create in your entire career you
think maybe like that yeah 20 or 30 and
because then I eventually figured out
how to just get the DMV to issue me the
goddamn license right I'm just gonna get
you to just just make it because then I
can go I can get pulled over by the cops
and hand him the real license makers on
it yeah yeah why would I why would I
keep making it easier yeah poses as a
single woman looking to rent this house
and Alpharetta
a suburb of Atlanta she meets with the
owner Michael Shanahan he and I talked
for a while and he was you know he was
very nice and and that was a heart that
because he was the only person that I
really met face to face grace Hudson
Rebekah's alias hardhome and Matt Cox
takes over the landlord's identity
what I did was I I used a child social
security number and I went got some
credit cards in his name what opened
some bank by the way which child was it
it was a child of and was family renting
it before you or what child no no you
said used the child social security
number I may I went to Social Security
right and I got them to issue a social
security number to a child that was ten
months old Oh got it so it's a child
it's a fake child's not a real child
right and I would then I would marry it
so I'd pull get credit cards in the name
of that with that so SH
in the name Michael Shanahan I've got
your driver's license mm-hmm the
driver's license that did the date of
birth and everything matches or that
everything matches right and I've got
these these uh credit cards and
everything issued to you I open up a
bank account in your name I open up
everything in your name now I'm it's
completely synthetic identity it because
the only thing it's the same is the name
everything else was different on him
date of birth address because I wasn't
using that address I used another
address because when we borrowed money
on that house we didn't borrow it as a
owner-occupied property we borrowed it
as a rental property because then
they'll issue the check right away and
hard money guys don't typically lend
money on owner-occupied properties they
prefer to lend money on investment
properties why is that I have no idea it
has something to do with the lending and
the ability to foreclose on it you
foreclose on investment property living
in it use harder foreclose on way more
difficult okay kick out hoping that none
of this would hit Michael Shanahan's
now posing as Michael Shanahan the owner
of this $200,000 house Cox goes looking
for money well I met the fellow calling
himself Michael Shanahan in this at the
front door here
remember those god Waldman is not a
faceless bank he'll end his own
hard-earned money to people who need
short term loans I was there a primarily
to see the condition of the house at the
time it didn't occur to me to wonder
about his identity or anything to that
effect
Cox posing as Michael Shanahan tells
Holman he wants to borrow money against
the equity in his home the man seems
trustworthy and the home is good
collateral the story was that he owned a
house free and clear and wanted to
borrow money against it to start a
business he had just moved back from the
UK wanted to start a business and needed
one hundred and ten thousand dollars or
so I bought it hook line and sinker
within a couple of weeks the deal is
done
holman has no idea cox is also talking
to a friend of his on what they call a
hard money lender like lend money mostly
to other investors buying properties to
renovate and resell sucker and he wants
$100,000 but they don't interview the
st. Martin Shanahan seems like a sure
thing it was a fifty percent loan to
value loan up in Alpharetta Georgia and
a beautiful neighborhood very low risk
lenders do their homework
Holman runs a title check on the house
and a background check on Shanahan at
the closing we got his ID and he had
actually more than the normal ID he had
Florida driver's license he had a credit
card and a social security card all in
the name Michael Shanahan so everything
checked out and we made the loan
thinking that we had secured interest in
the problem
a month later Peter saint-martin
realizes Michael Shanahan has missed his
first loan payment was gone by this I
pulled out like a month later like four
hundred thousand yeah
within a month yeah yeah we can that's
the one where I actually were in the
bank they go when I was pulling I was
trying to cash one of the checks as
Scott cugno
and they [ __ ] they're running a check
and everything remember the guy was
twenty nine thousand dollar check okay
and you called him from they and well
they called me on my phone they they're
like hey we're trying to verify this I
find my own check that which there is in
the book right okay so yeah and so I end
up getting a like for LeBron be like
$400,000 Becky and I get out four on
four hundred thousand and week within
weeks and we just take off like I didn't
know I didn't know these two guys know
each other [ __ ] chances are that I
mean how am I supposed to know so anyway
yeah this is when the Secret Service
gets involved but neither man is worried
each thinks he's the first in line to
foreclose if necessary and I'm happy
about it and I'm looking forward to
taking back this collateral and selling
it very quickly at a very nice profit
although we don't do these loans with
the purpose for getting the house back
it's not necessarily a disaster for us
but Matt Cox will have the last laugh
that's why I remember pretty similar to
that when I remember a short time later
the two friends are at a concert
together and they begin to compare notes
kind of saying well where is your
property you know cuz you do most so
John I were chatting and mentioned that
yeah we did this law and you're not
gonna you know this guy's first month
default blah blah blah I don't know what
rang up familiar Bell there but I asked
Peter what street was the low tone
mine was King him and you're like oh
Elsa don't oh it's the same property I'm
address and I said what was the guy's
name and he said Michael Shanahan he
said I said
unbelievable well the fact that he
borrowed money from you and me and we
both know each other and although i sat
there during the rest of that concert
thinking that I was probably out a
hundred and ten thousand dollars and not
real happy about it John Holman calls
the US attorney and you say the
insurance companies pay them back here
he says the one guy he says you already
got paid back he's one of the guys the
one guy the gray hairs right here he
shows up my sentencing really sure he's
the guy he's the one that showed up but
he shows up my sentencing and my US
attorney is like you know mr. Holmes or
whatever his name is um he he mr. [ __ ]
stole a hundred and ten thousand dollars
from from him and he they that was his
own money and he you know this is all he
does buy this guy's like a
multi-millionaire plus he's got a credit
line so I mean it's not like he works at
7-eleven anyway
he he you know stole his money he
couldn't afford to lose that much money
and you never got any of that money back
did you and he goes this is in front of
the judge at my sentencing he owes um
actually I did get the money back
she goes what what yeah I take it the
money back she was when did you get the
money back I mean this is [ __ ]
courtroom these [ __ ] reporters
stopped judging me
so anyway there's reporters and the
[ __ ] judge and they're having this
conversation it's like a fog on a
hundred people and the [ __ ] thing and
he and he's like we I did get the money
back and she's like well when and he's
like it was it was shortly after you
know month or two later I got it back
and she goes well well what about the
payments he missed he has no no I got
the payments back to what do well she
must be out something she's like no I
got I got everything back she goes what
about well what about an attorney's fees
anything oh no he's I did I did have to
pay some attorneys fees that was about
$1,500 yeah yeah I did pay some
attorneys fees and she's $1,500 well
that's a lot of money she's you couldn't
afford to lose that could you and he
goes um no no I couldn't I couldn't loot
there was a lot of money to me and it's
a it's like brawl I mean I mean not that
it's not [ __ ] up what I did not that
it's not that but you know it's you just
they're desperate to [ __ ] make you
look as bad as they possibly can yeah
here payback yeah from the Thailand guys
one of the guys well no the other guy
gets paid back to oh he just doesn't get
paid back during this episode mmm he's
been paid back okay he's not on my I
don't owe him money he's not a part of
my [ __ ] my restitution because he was
paid back and who paid him back the
title insurance
I said his entire title insurance yeah
company is on my restitution I owe them
the money okay so it's like if you say
oh you stole half a million dollars or
two million dollars from Bank of America
or five hundred thousand for 50 thousand
from Bank of America it's like yeah but
Bank of America got paid back so why are
you saying Bank of America because who I
really owe is lawyers title they pay
them back but see that's too complicated
so it's easier to say you stole this
money from me you know I never got paid
you owe Bank of them or you owe John and
so-and-so well actually I don't owe him
anything
right so but go ahead sorry his office
in Atlanta and the case is routed to the
US Secret Service the Secret Service
isn't just in the West Wing of the White
House more and more they're taking on
white-collar crime we we protect the
president and former presidents but we
also deal with any kind of financial
crime anything that affects the
financial infrastructure of the United
States Special Agent Andrea peacock
doesn't know who Michael Shanahan and
Grace Hudson really are it was John and
Jane Doe and we obtained our initial
warrants John Jane or in the name of
John and Jane Doe The Secret Service
creates a wanted poster and eventually
tracks down a former associate of Cox's
in Tampa he did in fact know who he was
and Scott told us his name was Matthew
Bevan Cox yoga agent peacock learns that
Matt Cox has taken out three loans on
Shanahan's property for a total take of
more than $300,000
Peter st. Martin is out of luck his
titled insurance will not cover the
law's $106,000 loss overnight to a small
business that could have easily put me
out of business at that time it hurts it
hurts badly that I don't have access to
that money
[Laughter]